bonjour je m'appelle c'est le petit
doigt
j'ai 26 ans et j'ai le permis b chercher
un secteur d'entreprises entre
saint-andré saint denis saint denis
saint paul
j'habite à saint denis juste du travail
en peinture bâtiment des plaquistes j'ai
un cap et un bep un bac et un bts et
tout ça en peinture peinture plaquiste
j'ai touché ce qui dit revêtements
muraux passagers un terroriste ayant
conduit
fin et les façades ravalement ce qu'ils
disent est invaincu à l'extérieur depuis
vingt dix couches heures à l'intérieur
ce que dira grillage c'est le projet
ciment
la finition j'ai travaillé onze ans en
sous traitance à badghis bébé est la
plus grosse boîte que j'ai travaillé
dans cette déconfiture je suis quelqu'un
de dynamique je suis polyvalent et je
suis très généreux je vous ai tout dit
de moi maintenant j'attends comme
beaucoup de filles j'attends que
beaucoup de fils vous prenez moi vous
allez vers et pas regretté
serez satisfait de mon travail j'attends
que vos appels
[Musique]